hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to four second friend a week
ago I have four seconds literally for
each game to complete them without dying
in the seven allotted lives that I have
and this is only normal mode ah [ __ ]
what's up dude a great start haha I did
it you bastard okay so there's 20 games
huh
why am I got a wheelchair on roofs this
is happy wheels here okay crack the eggs
I don't even know how I did that that's
awesome
iron the wrinkles oh crap Oh
avoid smash oh okay I did it
congratulations me shoot the target
where's the target
hand me got it did it
avoid lines oh hey I'm doing it good I
can't believe it nope not doing it oh I
guess I shouldn't speak so soon spread
the love hey how is that spreading the
love I dragged a heart from one person
to another wait what what ah what do you
want me to do
Russell safety haha closed easy enough I
guess how far do I have to go how many
lights do I have left okay
thank you geez I can't even I can't I
can't even keep humming again ah can't
even keep up with words to say make him
cool does that even mean
factor oh no he died huh ah no I lost
how can I lose I was doing so good
uh uh okay hang on tries again not a
skip that all right
to do this kid I can't beat normal but I
thought I might have been upgrading to
endurance mode in a second but no
apparently not till the teleporting what
how do you ah I fell into lava and then
I died bounced across well all right
then
cool I catch just for one Oh what once I
destroy Earth I don't wanna
oh why I tried take a Oh No said Motty
opportunity spread the love
damn it got with this love okay love Co
avoid smash
this game is a lot harder than you think
because your brain doesn't have time to
register what you want to do yeah so
buff and hairy for some reason why is it
so here take this I don't even know what
I am was I wasn't lines make him cool
this time he's not gonna die or
something no apparently he died never
mind
whatever then fall down I can do this
one oh there's a whole game based around
this mechanic Aiden Aiden what a 10-8 it
did I just want to make him a bee oh god
it was so close he almost wasn't happy I
would have been so sad yeah okay good
job guy defuse it red blue green oh oh
use a head ma'am okay I got only two
lives left I think I knew this hey
pommel is done shoot it - what fetch
water okay
shoot the target ah happy for second
frenzy what happens now what is all this
oh hi what are you I'm not playing again
what are you doing oh this is the bond
with the wizard ah what is this a boss
level you tell me there's gonna be a
boss level ah the sword Fair you didn't
even mention it you're not happy you're
mad I thought it was gonna beat it
inside four minutes there's gonna be
like a four minute episode miserably
ya know told me there's gonna be a boss
level at the end of that such bull oh
god damn it
alright don't worry I'm done I'm done
whatever this is this gonna be a really
short video so thank you all so much for
watching click the update' for more
videos that i've done check out the
other fast game that i played over there
and please get yourself in the
description below totally free online
available now flash game ok thank you
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye
thanks to my body